okay welcome everyone
to this free webinar on the upcoming
program
omixlogic transcriptomics today we'll
talk about
the program and some of the topics that
we will be covering
we'll also discuss some of our previous
experience with these kinds of training
programs in bioinformatics
and hopefully answering any questions
that you have
about the upcoming program so omixologic
transformatomics is an online training
program for students
researchers and clinicians and it is
designed to introduce participants to
the various aspects
of rna-seq data analysis in application
to basic research as well as in
biotechnology
and biomedical applications
so what i hope to do today is speak a
little bit about
how army seek is used for real world
biomedical applications and research
projects and what kinds of skills
you need to have to be able to handle
large rna-seq data and be able to
visualize analyze and interpret this
data
to study different types of biological
phenomena
a little bit about omics logic and our
programs
so the omnics logic programs are a
result of a close collaboration between
pine biotech
our company and which is based in the
u.s and numerous academic institutions
that have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design as a result
the onyx logic programs have been
thoroughly tested and are known to lead
to excellent outcomes for students and
faculty interested
in learning bioinformatics or
incorporating bioinformatics resources
into existing programs these programs
combine experience in bioinformatics and
terminology
of biological data as well as data
science skills
that are in high demand in industry
we've been testing these programs for
several years now
and we feel that the outcome of these
programs
is very encouraging because many of the
participants that we
have joining these programs are
continuing on to apply the skills that
they've used
to their own research or even in
industry
so what is omix omix technologies like
next generation sequencing
can be used to explore the roles
relationships
and actions of the various types of
molecules
that make up the cells of an organism
for example this is
an image of a cell which gives us
phenotypic data
about what these cells look like but
many types of omics data
can actually reveal molecular detail
about what is going on inside the cell
at the subcellular level
for example genomic data tells us about
variance at the dna level
epigenetic regulation of gene expression
has been of an increasing
interest for the past several decades
and today we can study this kind of
epigenetic regulation
by in the end by analyzing
chromatin immune precipitation data as
well as by sulfide sequencing data
and the expression of micro and long
non-coding rnas
but ultimately we want to understand
how the cell which functions and grows
is regulating the different activities
based on expression of mrna messenger
rna
that could be studied through
alternative splicing
how different genes are spliced together
by combining
exons as well as their level of
expression
which could be studied at both tissue
and single cell level so what we'll do
in this program
is we'll talk about some of the basics
of rna-seq
how processing mapping and
quantification of rna-seq data
how to explore the gene and isoform
expression data and how to prepare the
data for analysis
what type of normalization techniques
and
data pre-processing techniques make an
impact on our ability to interpret what
is going on
at the subcellular level we'll discuss
some of the statistical approaches
to analyze differences between
conditions
and identify statistically significant
features
of our data sets how we can then
look at what these features mean in
terms of their biological activity
and how we can combine them into gene
sets and
pathways and finally we'll talk about
machine learning
so we'll talk about how the advances in
machine learning and the
easy application of machine learning
made through different packages
and interfaces can allow us to study
detailed patterns within this large
rna-seq data
so that we can interpret differences
between cell types
tissue types and different types of
conditions
as a method of measuring rna translation
transcriptomic studies can help detect
mrna expression
inside the cell as an accurate
alternative to membrane protein
expression detection
which allows for molecular precision in
diagnostics and even development of
treatment
based on molecular pathways so when we
think about
rna-seq the utility of understanding
what types of proteins are being
produced provides us
with a clear understanding of what
happens inside
beneath the membrane of an individual
cell
which is very different from when we
talk about staining for proteins and
biomedical and diagnostic applications
and also provides us with a good insight
about potential
targets that could be targeted by
different drugs
as an important part of precision
medicine
this type of information is becoming
regularly useful
in different types of diagnostic
purposes for early detection
specific and personalized understanding
of what's happening
with a patient at the subcellular level
what is driving the disease
and exploratory analyses with
model organisms and cell lines where
a functional association between
different genes and variation in those
genes could be
understood and studied at a mechanistic
level
so to allow us to study this kind of
technology
over the past few decades several
different technologies have been
designed
designed and rna-seq refers to
this next generation sequencing
technology so rna-seq
or rna sequencing has revolutionized the
way biologists examine transcriptomes
and has been successfully applied in
biological research drug discovery and
clinical development
compared with microarray-based
transcriptome profiling
rna-seq has a wider dynamic range
meaning that it can detect many more
variations of
the same gene so many more transcripts
of a gene
because it is not based on hybridization
so it's not based on
probes designed to measure and detect
specific types of
mrnas rna-seq can measure the expression
levels of thousands of genes
simultaneously and provide
insights into functional pathways and
regulatory networks in biological
systems
in addition rnac can provide novel
insights
into alternative splicing unannotated
exons
and novel transcripts that have not been
previously annotated
most importantly such detail has already
proven to yield
significant discoveries in many research
areas
gene expression patterns in association
with clinical data so when we have both
the gene expression data and different
types of phenotypic data described
by what condition this is or maybe
even described in a continuous numeric
data like for example
ld50 can help identify molecular
biomarkers for diagnostics and therapy
selection
like biomarkers and these new
discoveries
also include a better better
understanding of complex diseases for
example like cancer that include
um aberrant expression and
changes in isoforms or exome splicing
and this understanding of these complex
diseases ultimately leads us to
appreciation of the variability of the
disease at an individual patient level
it is also helpful to identify targets
for novel drug design and repurposing
and
requires an understanding of both the
data
preparation how the data is stored and
annotated
and ability to find associations
and measure them to be able to address
these important challenges
so in this program we'll discover how
rna-seq data can be used to study the
role of
tumor microenvironment in tumor growth
or regulation
which could be studied for
differentially expressed genes
in different types of conditions when we
compare
different conditions or control
experiments and analyze to find markers
of
cell and tissue types in
neurodegenerative
neurodegenerative diseases so we've
prepared
curated data sets and projects that we
will be able to explore
as we learn about the basics of rna-seq
data
so this program our mix logic
transcriptomics
includes six sessions that are
interactive sessions
with a mentor they also include access
to a variety of different resources that
you will have access to during the
program
and an ability to work on an independent
project
so let's take a look at some of these
sessions and the topics that will be
covered
in these sessions in the first session
we will
describe all of the tools and resources
for transcriptomic data analysis so
we'll discuss a lot of different
material that was prepared
for the program specifically and how to
use some of these tools
in the next session we'll discuss the
basics of
processing next generation sequencing
data using what's called bioinformatics
pipeline so we'll discuss the concept of
pipelines
and we'll also discuss specific types of
pipelines
that can help us generate different type
of transcriptomic data
at the gene or isoform level including
bulk and single cell rnac
then we'll discuss analysis
normalization and visualization of gene
and isoform expression we'll do this
using both cloud-based tools that are
intuitive and easy to use to
understand the logic of analysis and
also
discuss some of the typical packages in
both r
and python for analysis and
visualization of such data
in session four we'll introduce big data
mining
and machine learning for predictive
analysis so we'll discuss how
the emergence of big data in such
studies like rna-seq
has led to an ability to mine publicly
available data sets
find interesting associations and
develop
novel hypotheses we'll also talk about
how
machine learning allows us to deploy
machine learning predictive models
to learn from data that is already
available
and predict something new about novel
data sets or data sets from other
repositories
that could be very useful for
classification
early detection and development of
biomarkers
in session five we'll speak about the
analysis of single cell rna-seq
how we can analyze single-celled data so
what kinds of
pipelines and standard packages exist
for the analysis and the processing of
the data
what are some of the challenges
associated with rna-seq data
what are some examples where analysis of
single cell data have
proven to be insightful and important
and also discuss tissue specific
expression so in fact how we can take
markers from different tissues
discovered through
single cell rna-seq and apply
decomposition of bulk rna-seq data
in session six we'll take a look at a
few hands-on
project examples and these will be from
the domain of cancer biology
infectious diseases and biotechnology so
we'll provide a few different examples
and using these examples you'll be able
to develop
a project of your own and in that
project of your own
we will guide you how to find the data
how to then
process that data and prepared for
analysis
analyze and prove or disprove a
hypothesis
and then visualize and showcase the
results of your analysis in an
impactful way now you can see
on the chat there's a link to
a page where you can find all of this
information
so all of the questions about what
topics and sessions are included
as well as the course costs and
different
options are described on this page so
let's take a look at this page together
so this is the page thank you
okay so all you need to do is go to
transcriptomics.omixlogic.com
so this is the page you can see that
it's going to start on
15th of september we have four days and
eight hours and we're counting down to
the beginning of this program
and you can also start looking at
different sessions
and topics that are going to be covered
in the program and also the calendar of
those sessions so essentially we're
talking about two weeks
in these two weeks we will cover a lot
of the basics in the first week
and then go on to more advanced topics
in the second week
and then you will have another two weeks
to develop and work on your independent
project
now in many cases when we interact with
participants of our program
they are interested in having a mentor
guide their selection of a data set help
them develop the project
idea and even help and assist to guide
their analysis
now we do have that option available as
well
so as we thought about how to structure
this program
we were thinking about different
packages that we could provide to
participants that could benefit the most
from completing a program getting
certification
developing a project idea and actually
applying some of these skills
to a data set or a research question of
their own
so that's why if you go up here and you
click on get started you will see
a few different options which includes
access
to the program courses that we will take
a look at
in a second access to our coding
exercise platform where you can
code learn how to apply different
packages and also get help
and feedback on some of your code or
errors that you're getting
access to the interactive sessions where
we discuss in detail
some of these topics and answer any kind
of questions
or discuss any technical challenges that
you have
also access to research projects in
other words you'll be able to
analyze your own data and get guidance
on the analysis of your own data from
a technical perspective and optional
mentor support so that
mentor support also means that you'll be
able to interact in a one-on-one session
with a mentor
ask any questions get your answers and
also be able to
use that help to make your project
better refined
and more ready for prime time for others
to see
so those are some of the choices now if
you scroll down you will see as we
mentioned some of these
topics explained and here you'll see
some of the benefits from these programs
also down at the bottom there's some
feedback that we've gotten in the course
of our previous programs that you can
take a look at
and the description of the coursework
that we will go through
in detail in this presentation
so the omixlogic programs include a
variety of resources
that you can benefit from and also be
flexible
with your schedule making the most of
your time
for this program on transcriptomics we
will combine
online sessions self-guided study
materials
that you can complete on your own time
and
practical assignments and as a result we
hope that
everyone will be benefiting from an
immersive
experience and what we've seen in the
past
is that the most of these elements
actually work seamlessly together
to have an effective outcome
for our previous and ongoing omics logic
programs and we have a few others that
are ongoing
as well that i'll be able to share in a
little bit
so let's look at some of these resources
one by one
throughout the program you will be
accessing
some of these online asynchronous
resources
that provide a broad and yet detailed
overview
of processing statistical analysis
and machine learning tools as well as
understanding of single cell data types
and
analysis techniques the courses cover
methods
expand on the specific terminologies
associated with each type of analysis or
data
and provide practical examples they also
include
quizzes for self-evaluation and
assignments
so let's take a look at some of these
courses and what they include
okay so this is a link specifically to
the different collections of courses
throughout the program you'll have
access to many of these courses not all
but many of them
but specifically we will focus on this
collection of transcriptomics courses so
you can
read here about each individual course
and what it includes
as a part of the program all of these
resources are going to be free for you
and they actually fit in very nicely
into the program schedule that we have
looked at already
so in transcriptomics one we discuss
what is next generation sequencing and
how is it different from
first generation sequencing we also
talked about the biology of
mrna expression and how it could be
related to different
pathways and signaling and metabolic
pathways
at the subcellular level that we need to
or seek to understand
by not by analyzing such data
in transcriptomics 2 we turn to
statistical analysis so we discuss
how statistics has been utilized to
understand
the differences between conditions or
groups of samples
and what are some of the considerations
around doing that kind of analysis and
interpreting the results
we also talked about annotation
biological annotation of pathways
and gene ontology terms and think about
different applications in a variety of
directions
in transcriptomics 3 we turn to machine
learning
and machine learning as you know is
divided up broadly
into two types unsupervised or data
mining
and supervised or classification so we
discuss
a few examples based on some practical
applications in the context of precision
medicine
how can we understand and classify
build a classifier that can predict
different types of subtypes of cancer
in transcriptomics four we turn to
single cell data
this is a new technology there are still
different methods in development but
therefore
but there have been some established
pipelines that are now being
standardly used to process and produce
a table of single cell gene and isoform
expression data
because that data comes from a very
different type
of data preparation method you also have
to have a number of considerations when
you look and analyze the patterns
that have been made through that kind of
a processing pipeline so that's what
this course is all about
in addition to the online courses this
program is designed to give you a sense
of practical analysis
tools and we want to make this as
approachable and as useful for a wide
variety
of participants both those that do have
some
technical background like coding and
those that do not
but most importantly we're going to be
analyzing
big data sets so these are going to be
tens of samples at a time
as you know a single sample of rnac data
could range anywhere between hundreds of
megabytes to
a number of gigabytes and so processing
such data sets on your own computer
is going to be time consuming and
ineffective
so as a part of the omics logic
transmitomics program you will have
access to the t-violin for platform that
provides
an interactive learning experience the
platform
is color coded to help establish a
logical connection
between the theoretical aspects of data
analysis methods
and the practical steps to achieve a
biologically
interpretable results so this is what's
called the bioinformatics pipeline
in this pipeline every step of the way
you will get an informative pop-up that
explains the
logic of why we are performing a certain
step
discusses the inputs and outputs of
every step
along the way and guides your
processing so that you can understand
what are the typical mistakes that you
can avoid by focusing on the correct
method
for the correct data set with the right
type of an output in mind
as a result instead of spending time on
building the pipeline you get the
ability to practice the pipeline
application different methods with
different types of settings
produce different types of outcomes and
results and so you will benefit from
making those results
throughout the program and being able to
explore how these results could be
interpreted
from a biological perspective
now what's important is that many
different pipelines are designed to
produce
different types of outputs and we can go
to a very detailed
read level analysis where we can
understand the mapping quality
and the read alignment for different
types of data that is being prepared
to then understanding the outputs or the
gene expression
table gene or isoform expression table
we'll talk about how to read these
different types of
outputs visualize them and also perform
analysis to summarize and explore the
specific
patterns within the data that we prepare
in transcriptomics three we'll dis we'll
we'll spend a significant time to
understand
machine learning or data mining and
classification
with the exponential growth of data many
are turning to machine learning to study
complex relationships at the subcellular
level
and develop data-driven research with
important
outcomes for human health so in this
program we'll have a chance to see
machine learning in action including
data mining techniques like clustering
dimensionality reduction like principal
component analysis
classification like random forest can
support vector machines
and feature selection algorithms that
are both
stepwise greedy and selection based
so we'll cover a wide variety of topics
that are related to
both processing these big data sets then
analysis
from a statistical perspective and
understanding how these more
complex machine learning methods are
practically applied
in really clear examples which i'll talk
about
in a second so let's take a look at how
this process will actually work
during this program you'll have access
to
the t by info platform now all of you
whether you're going to be a participant
in the program or not
are welcome to try this platform by
requesting a demo account
if you do request a demo account you'll
immediately get access to the interface
where you can explore a variety of
different sections
including next generation sequencing
data mass spectroscopy
structural biology and data integration
and modeling let's take a look at the
rna-seq
section to understand what it will look
like
here we've prepared a number of
different examples you can see from
cancer cell line projects ankleman
disease which is a neurodegenerative
disorder
and patient-derived xenograph models to
understand the
effect of microenvironment changes on
tumor growth
inside the interface you can now select
different methods
to build a pipeline it all starts with
the start and here you will see how
different types of methods
that are described in the further
sections
are used for what types of applications
you can then see that only a small
number of options are highlighted
and so based on your preference you can
select
pre-processing steps that clean up the
reeds
and help you focus on only high quality
reads
eliminating contamination from such
things
as adapter ligation and pcr
amplification
then we can look at mapping techniques
to the reference genome or
transcriptome and develop a sense
of how high is the expression for a
particular gene or
isoform ultimately
looking at the gene expression table
so once this pipeline is complete you'll
be able to see
some of the output files and we'll
discuss downstream
analysis i'm going to pause here and i
see that there's a few
questions so i'll just briefly address
those questions if you have any
questions about what i've shown so far
please put them in the chat
okay so how will all of these
topics be covered in six sessions only
as a result of combining the interactive
sessions
which are about one and a half hours
long
together with a synchronous material
that you will have access to
on your own we expect that you will be
able to get
a very good understanding of many of the
topics that i'm discussing here
and also try to apply them to an
independent project
however the whole program is about a
month long
so if you don't have a lot of time on
your hands you will have
additional time after the interactive
sessions
to go through the asynchronous material
and review the recorded sessions which
will be posted on the forum
so that you can make the most out of the
time after the interactive sessions
have been completed
okay what is the rna-seq pipeline so
what you're looking at now
is the rna-seq pipeline a pipeline
means that data from a script
or a job has been submitted to the net
script
and in a sequential manner the pipeline
produces
outputs that are used by the next
consecutive method
to give you the final output so this is
called
a pipeline now beyond this pipeline
which seeks to produce structured data
from
unstructured data which comes out
directly from the sequencer
we will also look at how to analyze such
data
for example we can look at
the data in the gene expression table
to study different patterns and even
visualize them
because there's so many elements to
analyze this could be done
in an automated way using different
types of scripts
okay about my voice breaking i'm really
sorry about
maybe the connection quality is not that
great
and i think if anyone else has this
issue
please let us know we'll also provide a
recorded version of this webinar
you can you can hear me fine uh yeah we
can hear you clearly
thank you okay great is there any
chance of publishing the paper or data
in case of research
project package yes the objective for
those that select
the research package is to provide you
with
an opportunity to develop an independent
project
and make sure that that project gets to
a level of completion
when you can actually analyze the data
and showcase what you have discovered
now as you know publication itself
requires additional steps like peer
review and replying to different
questions from your
peer review process so we are not going
to guarantee that you're going to be
able to publish but we have definitely
seen a number of participants
that have been able to achieve
meaningful results
and we even have a few examples on our
uh on a page uh maybe beep so you could
put
paste a link to the project description
with a few examples of participants that
have made
excellent projects sometimes these
projects take
a longer time and so we also have an
internship or what we call a
research fellowship program that's
intended
for three to six months and during that
time you have plenty of
opportunities to interact with mentors
and a community of like-minded
bioinformaticians
that are going to help you make the most
out of your independent project
so beeps if you have the link to the
internship page that would be also
useful right now
so another part of what we will do is
use
a coding platform now encoding itself in
both
r and python is very meaningful and
useful for
anyone that is interested in
bioinformatics now
some of you might already have some
skills in basic r and python
but what we seek to provide in this
program is an
opportunity to learn apply and
combine together different scripts to
make the most out of the data
so let me show you how that would work
throughout this course in the program
itself
you'll have access to tutorials that
will explain how to
load data and check the different data
types
perform exploratory analysis doing
descriptive statistics and visualization
and then focus on dimensionality
reduction
differential gene expression
hierarchical clustering
and different methods of classification
so as you go on to this platform you'll
find that
inside you will have some
explanation in both r or python
on how to perform these steps learn
about different types of
code and syntax and then
apply this to a data set
that is described in the program itself
so when you learn how to do this you
will actually
be able to run a code
you will get errors or success and also
will be able to monitor
and record your progress as you go
through this process
so for example here i have just prepared
some summary
plots that allow me to understand what
my data looks like
and by changing some of these examples i
can also modify
how this is going to look in the end so
for example here you can see i can
change the colors
or change which data set i'm going to be
using
and for example let's just change
briefly this
code from red to blue
okay and you can see that we got a blue
box plot
so those are the types of exercises that
you'll be able to go through
and this is also going to be included
for a whole month
and after that month you'll have a
discounted subscription option
if you're interested to continue and
learn not only these things in the
context of rna-seq
but also our full data science
curriculum
most importantly i believe that you
actually understand the most of the
significance of rna-seq
and understanding gene expression from a
biological perspective
when you get to apply this to data sets
that
make sense to data sets that you
understand the challenge
and where you understand what the data
was prepared to do
so we'll take a look at a number of
interesting examples taken from
high impact journals that are peer
reviewed
we'll take the data and we'll also
discuss how to find such data
on repositories like ncbi and
look at them in the context of different
types of applications for example for
cancer we'll talk about patient-derived
cell lines
patient-derived xenograft models and
clinical trials and translational
applications in repositories like
the cancer genome atlas or tcga
in depth we'll go into some examples
where we discuss
what are the challenges for example in
breast cancer classification it's
important to
rely on molecular subtypes to discuss
different treatment options and risk
associated with different types of
therapies so we'll talk about
how these different subcellular profiles
can help us
identify molecular classes and
what do those classes mean in the
context of diagnostics and treatment
can we download the sessions and other
inputs for a future reference
of course we will provide you and i will
get to that in a second
we'll provide you with recorded
materials from all of the sessions
you will get access to all of our course
material that is also
available in a pdf format and you'll
also get
access to the data sets that we have
practiced and used
throughout the session so you will have
that after this program
is over one of the projects that we'll
discuss
is modeling precision medicine in cancer
so here we will take a paper that is
called modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer where a
number of different cell lines were
prepared
and accessed by the researchers from the
public domain
and developed a classifier that
accurately predicts
how responses to different treatments
will be
based on the molecular profile but also
by using
training data from response and
measurement
of inhibition of growth 50
so 50 of the inhibition of growth
as a result if you look just through the
article uh itself you'll see how we will
learn about
molecular profile uh what are these
features
how to predict therapeutic responses
what are optimal predictors what is
molecular pathobiology
omix data and how to select most
predictive molecular feature sets
so you'll get access to a number of
projects that are really broken
down and clarified in terms of
what is the objective what is the data
and how to apply
the different methods of analysis to
discover such important path
patterns and be able to speak about them
and present them to your peers now many
of our previous participants have been
able to leverage these programs
to then go on and start discussing the
projects that they have worked on
in the context of their future journey
so here you can see some of the previous
participants of our programs that had a
chance to
present at conferences and by the way i
want to mention that right now
for these kinds of online programs this
is a good time because you can actually
present
virtually in many conferences that are
upcoming if you are interested to
publish
a poster session is probably going to be
your first step to validate and get some
feedback on your idea
after that as you develop your passion
in a particular
area or maybe you already have maybe
you're already
using rna-seq and data analysis skills
for a particular
type of projects you can then
build on your expertise in other areas
to advance your research career
for example we have seen a number of
participants
that have come from either bachelor
degree
master degree post doc or phd
or postdocs that have been able to
benefit from the program
for example olga udartseva from roswell
park comprehensive cancer center
mentioned that the program from her
perspective is very well structured and
easy to learn
the skills that she gained through the
program helped me significantly enhance
the relevance of my project by making
connections between my pre-clinical
study
and its practical applications to cancer
patients
so we're not just talking about learning
about rna-seq
our goal is to empower you to then apply
the different bioinformatics tools
repositories
and data sets to actually make research
discoveries
and apply them to practical problems
now she's not the only participant and
have provided with such feedback we
believe that
that we have had in our previous
programs have been able to benefit from
these programs and as a result we have
them available
both in this online fashion where you
can just join online
or through different universities for
example
in louisiana we are offering such
training through the louisiana
biomedical research network
in india we have partner institutions
that are able to provide these courses
to their
participants as well as a new program
that we are launching in
africa with a number of partner
universities that are going to offer
such
coursework and resources to their
students
so the program is going to be starting
on september 15th
so that's just in four days from now
remember that you'll have access to
processing pipelines
we'll discuss different methods of
visualization and how to build that
visualization using different types of
packages
coding skills as well as tools we'll
discuss statistical analysis
approaches how to do hypothesis
testing and how to interpret the results
we'll discuss
data mining how do we mine the complex
big data sets that are available online
with thousands of samples and how to
extract
meaningful uh patterns and meaningful
associations from that kind of data
and then we'll also talk about
interpretation what are some tools
that can aid us in visualizing our
results
and being able to interpret them by
using different
reference databases for annotation
at this point i would like to ask if you
have any questions or if i could clarify
any part of the program itself the omics
logic transcriptomic
program will allow you to learn about
rna-seq data processing analysis
and interpretation leverage cloud-based
tools for hands-on assignments
apply machine learning to large
biomedical data sets
complete and present an independent
research project and
obtain a certificate of excellence and
gain recognition
from our community
and if you have any questions please
paste them on chat
i want to briefly mention how the
program is structured and for those of
you that have already registered i know
that
many people have already registered for
the program so just to
explain what would be the next steps
once you are registered you will gain
access to
our program page and this is the program
page i'll mix logic transcriptomics
2020.
here you will see courses that are
included in the program
project examples progress where we track
the progress and you can also evaluate
your progress
from a perspective of the rest of the
group
attract assignments and also see the
syllabus
and the faculty of the program
we also utilize the forum on this forum
we will be
basing session recordings highlighting
top performers
and also pasting any additional
information that we think is beneficial
to those
that are interested in rna-seq so these
are going to be publications
different types of review articles
and data sets that we are utilizing in
the program
about financial support we are very
interested in helping
anyone who is passionate about learning
bioinformatics
gain skills and apply them in a
meaningful way
we offer scholarships for those that
have the time and the dedication to go
through these programs and
develop an independent project you
are welcome to reach out to marketing
at pine.bio with any clarification
about offers for a scholarship
so you do have to have some previous
background in either molecular biology
or some kind of bioinformatics so that
you are
comfortable with the materials and you
have to be
please email marketing at pine.bio
so on this page you will see all of the
relevant materials this page is going to
be
available to those that have already
registered you'll see
the upcoming schedule for each one of
our sessions
and you'll also see any kind of activity
here
and get help from our mentors to address
any technical
challenges throughout the program
after completing this program can
participate apply for scholarship
programs
you can definitely apply there's a
variety of different scholarship
options i also want to mention that we
do have
a linkedin group and a facebook group
that we invite you to join maybe beeps
so you could post those links
in those groups we regularly post
opportunities for
uh different types of internships or
even job
offers um in terms of scholarships so
as i mentioned before we do have a
a program for internships
let me just open that one
which is a research fellowship that is
either
three or six months conducted completely
online for those of you that might be
interested in that
in the research fellowship you gain a
lot of
assistance from like-minded
bioinformaticians as well as from our
team
to help you develop an independent
project and complete it in the course of
time that you're registered for
and we believe that if you're interested
in a scholarship program or you're
interested to get into a particular
program or a lab
typically what is required is for you to
come prepared
right a lot of pis a lot of universities
are looking for students that are
prepared that are ready
to start their job or start their
position running
and so we believe that developing a
project
in the specific topic of that lab or
that university or that
company can really help you advance
your uh career in that field so we do
offer uh support and access to a lot of
the tools
and regular weekly sessions that you can
join here
you can again fill out the form on this
page if you're interested specifically
in this you get access to all of our
learning materials
and by registering filling out this
registration form
you will start receiving emails about
the specifics and the details and we can
also schedule
a one-on-one meeting if you're
interested in joining that program to
evaluate the best fit
and discuss what you might want to do to
prepare for
such a program
okay so if there are no other questions
um i would like to also introduce
uh dr maheed mazumdar who is going to be
also helping with this program
mohit if you would like to say a few
words about the program
um or anything you think might be
relevant at this point
thank you india hello everyone
yes uh for this transcriptomics program
uh
which will be starting on monday
we will be uh helping you out with
the registration on the website on the
portal
on the educational platform and uh give
you the access
to the courses that uh we described
today
in the today's session and uh we will
have
uh we will be also sending you the
access to the tv and for server account
so that you can start applying those
methods
and see how you can
design those pipelines as well so
if you need any help regarding the
registration
uh uh do let us know if you face any
trouble uh reach out to us
at marketing at the red pine dot bio and
uh
we'll be looking forward to uh have you
uh on
monday yeah thank you india
okay excellent thank you and thank you
everyone for joining today
some of the questions um do you get a
discount if you register today
uh so please uh reach out to marketing
at pine by at pine dot bio
uh you will see when you get started uh
there is an
option here to get a coupon uh
so if you are interested in a discount
or a scholarship
uh you need to discuss that with
marketing at pine.bio
we review every case with a lot of
consideration
we're really interested in more than
just a program
that you walk away with with a
certificate from
we're interested in building a community
that continues to learn together and
actually applies these skills to
different types of research projects so
we're definitely
happy to have everyone who is passionate
about bioinformatics on board
thank you for joining today again the
recording in the session will be made
available
there are other programs but all of them
are
in bioinformatics we do discuss aspects
of cellular biology immunology
infectious diseases
and etc but in the context of data
analysis
and we are very very passionate about
the
data part of each one of those topics
that you've
mentioned and in fact what we try to do
in our sessions
is not only discuss about the data
analysis methods and the statistics and
the computer side of things but we also
touch on many aspects of
cellular biology immunology and other
topics
that are important to understand when
you deal with biological projects and
biological data
any courses in cancer biology so in
uh the courses that we we have we
include
introductions to different types of
projects
so when we look at the
let's look at the schedule here
we believe that in the beginning you
should get some basics
and be able to independently analyze
data
and so that's what the first part of
this program is going to be focused on
then we'll actually discuss a number of
project
examples and how to find publicly
available rnc
data so a lot of our examples are going
to be related to cancer
at both cancer biology and immunology in
the sense that
the cancer develops and then
causes disease in different areas of the
body
we do have a separate program on
oncology
which is not this program this is
specifically on transcriptomic but
transcriptomic data is
excellent to study cancer particularly
different types of cancer like breast
cancer etc
but we also apply the same
to the immunology of infectious diseases
when we look at the host response to
different pathogens
and we also discuss different types of
approaches to
agriculture understanding of differences
in crop production stress responses
and others so if you need a little bit
more information on the different types
of projects that we
offer or that we discuss in the context
of the program
you can take a look right here these are
some of the
some of the projects that you will have
as your practice
throughout the program you can see here
that we have identification of
novel pathogens in cell lines that are
used for biologics production
ebola virus some of these are not going
to be available for
the whole public but we will still rely
on them in the courses
crop drought stress and resistance
targeted medicine or cancer biomarkers
in early stage detection of breast
cancer neurodegenerative diseases like
alzheimer's disease
analysis of changing immune responses in
cancer this is a study of macrophage
changes
over time patient-derived genograph
models allows us to study the
microenvironment and tumor development
and modeling precision medicine which i
already touched on in this course
now we do have a number of other
examples that we're going to be
doing including liver cancer
tuberculosis
as well as covert maintain immunology
so there's a lot of material that is
prepared obviously in
such a short time we're not going to be
able to cover
everything but we will provide you
access with some curated data sets
and explain some of the basics that will
get you started
and help you develop an independent
project idea
um and whether you select the package
with the mentorship or not
we'll try to work with you hands-on to
actually allow you to get the most out
of the program
okay so again thank you everyone for
joining it was a pleasure to
see so many people interested
um about the pre-requirements there's
not really any
major pre-requirements to just join the
program you do have to have some
basic uh well
so to join the program itself you do
need to have some basic terminology
in molecular biology in fact
what we recommend for everyone we have a
free course that is called
introduction to bioinformatics sorry
introduction uh to bioinformatics
that we recommend for everyone to start
with this is a free course
so you can actually join and register
today
and go to this introduction to
bioinformatics course now this course
is not your standard introduction to
bioinformatics where you learn the very
basics
it talks about different types of
applications different types of projects
different types of data sets it talks
about many different things in a very
short period of time
and you can see just based on the
reviews
how many different people have been able
to
benefit from completing this course
now after you go through this course you
will also get a sense
of what this these courses in general
are going to be like
and you'll see that even faculty members
at different universities were able to
benefit from
just completing this free course so it's
a free resource to get started
we also get to learn about you in this
course
and that helps us adjust our programs to
make sure that they
are providing great outputs for
those participants of our programs so
you can really
try to explore the materials here
provide us with some information about
your background your educational
background your other experience in
bioinformatics
and we will be reaching out to you based
on your feedback
from the course material itself but also
based on your
information
okay so hopefully i've been able to
answer all of the questions that you
might
have if you do have any other questions
feel free to reach out to us by email or
complete this introduction to my
informatics course for free
and provide us with some more
information about you
we would be happy to stay in touch as
well
okay and uh we also offer a number of
other programs that are coming up
um briefly those are programs
in different parts of the world that
focus on the application of
bioinformatics
to different types of data as well as to
different types of challenges biomedical
epidemiology as well as agriculture
so please stay in touch we do about two
programs per month um and if you are
interested in a particular topic
we're always uh looking for new ideas
and uh to develop new programs thank you
and have a good rest of your day